foreign
don't worry Paul I just started
you crossed oh okay
so uh there is a handout today
which I'll which hasn't arrived yet but
which will arrive momentarily and uh
it's a it's a uh preparation for
Wednesday's talk which will be by herb
will
the first of our distinguished guest
lectures and uh
and this is an example of something that
he published very recently it was when
he when he first took over for the uh
uh uh the math monthly so this was
January this year uh where he where he
gives an introduction he decided uh to
be uh very courageous and and right at
almost monthly column uh where he would
try to present some interesting
mathematical Exposition and this was uh
and and so the this is just an example
of his writing that you can look over
before if you actually hear him in
person on Wednesday uh showing uh the
style that uh that he has for exposition
I wanted to show you a couple other
things of his as we get going this is
something that I received in February
this year uh paper that never actually
got published afterwards but uh worth
looking at let me see if I can find it
oh okay
here's a
um this is a draft that he that he sent
me see February and uh and I was wanted
to mostly show you the beginning of it
so TV man let me just show the beginning
okay so here you have um
um now one of the things he mentioned to
me is that uh and I think this is this
this tends to be true that somehow
sometimes the title of a of a paper is
too good to pass up and you think of a
good title then you have to write the
paper
um and uh he's got um
uh he's writing one now about uh
about the asteroid called series and and
something about the World Series uh
which he thought of and it's just
exciting what
no no asteroid
um c-e-r-e-s uh but it's I do some
interesting mathematical calculations
associated with discovering this uh in
the 19th century and he's researching
that the history of that with with some
archives at Berkeley and uh uh anyway uh
so here's a a lovely a lovely title
um although um I would have kept
capitalized the end uh which um since
it's the first word in the title I don't
know and and uh I said before that that
it's too even even so I wouldn't have to
put it in italics maybe consider it as
an English word uh I mean everybody
knows uh uh the N is an English I mean
like I and O are English words uh o is
usually mostly used in poetry but we
have uh but n is uh we talk about n
Tuple and that sort of uh you know we
have N Dash which is spelled a little
different but uh it probably could be
considered in a mathematical journal to
be a could be an English word letter N
um
uh I I your attorney destroy the title
by by leaving out the mathematics in in
this particular example
um uh so I showed you and I showed you
the gauss's thing that had too much
mathematics in the title but maybe this
is tolerable there was a there was a
paper by Ron ravest
and um
and Andy Yao
uh about 10 years ago called n plus one
heads are better than n
and this was uh uh this was a
generalization of the well-known result
that two heads are better than one and
uh and it was actually uh a deep result
on the theory of Turing machines uh that
would show that if you had uh
if you had a tape if you had a turing
machine with uh with with 11 reading
heads it could actually go faster than a
throwing machine with 10 reading heads
and things like that so they had this so
but it's rare that you can have a title
like that anyway that but he would but
it's clear that he liked the title in
that and now now what's the fountain and
so then he he says a fountain is an
arrangement of n coins in rows such that
they're exactly K Coins at the bottom
row and each coin Hyrule touches two
others
um and then he has figure one a fountain
and it's clear then why it's called a
fountain and I call it coins in a
fountain and then makes the uh
makes a nice picture and an appealing uh
it's appealing to read this because
partly because it's short and because
you can expect that it'll have some
interesting
mathematics and he um
and uh he the point is that he wants to
show that has an amazing generating
function shown in sixth below which is
uh which is that which is this function
here and um and then after I saw this I
told him how to tell Tech not to
uh type said it's so funny and put a
little more space there above that X and
and uh
and uh there's a thing in the textbook
about this in fact
um
but this paper was never published
because uh we uh found out that it had
already appeared this is the other
people had discussed this very thing
um before and so they didn't have such a
nice title for their paper and so on but
the paper died about two weeks later
because uh several of us started looking
at we learned much more about these
about these fountains and we're finally
learned so much that we were able to
find where they had already appeared and
uh in other places
um
let's see uh that's the um
um the only others but but the uh I
think you'll enjoy the lecture on
Wednesday and this is a little intro to
it another thing that's current is today
in in today's mail I received
from the ACM some something that I
haven't had chance to look at very
carefully yet but it's Galley proofs
that have come for for a paper so this
is part of a part of mathematical
writing so since it came today I thought
I should I show you this so here's a
um although it's dated September 30th I
don't know how that happens
um
here it is uh maybe they do that North
and make the author feel really guilty
for not returning the galley proofs the
same immediately huh um
uh and uh within 48 Hours look at that
so I'm like okay but it is yeah it is
something that's supposed to interrupt
me maybe I shouldn't come and teach this
class today you know I should be I
should be doing these guys well um now
so I look quickly to see if they had so
what does it look like so here they have
uh they have given me the captions or
the figures and they give me the uh the
subheads uh that will be running on the
top of the page like theoretically I'm
supposed to check each one of these to
see if one of them is misspelled and the
others are are not but I know they give
this by a computer so I should only have
to check one right
um and then I look at the alcohol
programs and as you and uh since this is
ACM they've done this a lot and so I and
as you can expect this is this looks
like it's coming out pretty good
um it says in the margin bad proof
camera copy okay
I mean meaning that they um they
probably did this on a laser printer and
they but it'll look okay when they do it
on a high quality machine I don't know
um
and uh so and actually they've got
they've done a
um uh you know they've done a lot of
pre-marking already that they here they
uh had some glitch in their type setting
system that they they know about that
and uh here they have an author now they
have some notes to me Au is is author
you should realize this is uh you know
AAU you become a you when you be when
you start communicating with uh with
other people and uh and here it says per
Fowler okay so um uh they must have
changed my word uh uh here
um I must have said more clever way and
they preferred to say cleverer uh it
doesn't bother me but I really had
trouble
uh but I got upset when Scientific
American changed more common to commoner
um
and uh uh that didn't sound right at all
to me and I and I and I call them about
that but this one was all
incredible I don't know if I would have
said more clever there but Fowler says
and they and so they had so in other
words this is indication that a copy
editor has gone over this right and um
and now um
uh here it says
another question to uh to Au here
um
and I don't know why what what I don't
know that I can't talk about that
because I don't understand what the what
they're doing here
um but here they said okay to delete out
here yes I had a typo in my manuscript I
said the minimum possible of value of in
my original I remember noticing that
after I'd sent it off to them and so
they they certainly they even queried
that though so so I can see that they're
being very careful about uh about making
changes and um
uh and this is a note from the printer
not from the copy editor the ptrs the
notes from the printer so the printer uh
uh caught that as he was the guy was
keyboarding re-keyboarding the file
that's already in in electronic form but
they always do that still
um uh there's new journals coming out
now where the the keystrokes will go
will stay in the author's form and be
edited by
electronically instead of by retyping
the whole thing in uh that's that's just
now happening in new journals
some AI journals I guess have been doing
now already but it's been getting that
beginning to happen but this has been
already redone uh you can even see that
uh what kind of a type setting system
they have here because it each line uh
has a has a number so that they can go
back and make the corrections by line
number uh they must have had to do a lot
in between here when they get to these
fractions so it must be a very
complicated system that they're using
whatever they do it
at Waverly press here but they they it
comes it look comes out looking good
um and um
and so the printer is asking me whether
or not they got this this formula right
here here's a interesting thing comment
to to a author need to cite figures in
order
opening sentence okay so they must have
added it they must have given another
sentence in there that I didn't write
and so they're making sure that I okay
it
um uh examples of other methods are
shown in figures 13 to 16 smoothed out
diffusion appears in figures 14 and 16.
I must have
given some kind of a
introduction that mentioned first figure
14 before I mentioned figure 13 so they
uh they blocked at that and uh I should
have known better
um
and now look at this this is going to be
work
awesome please Supply here's a in the
bibliography
um
uh this is uh
Conference of spie number 310 and these
things are always
very difficult to find in Turman Library
here where we are but please Supply One
location conference to City of
conference what's the difference uh
three date four public publisher five
city of publication
um and um
you know asking more more information
about these things here now actually I I
thought I was was being rather virtuous
in applying as much as I did based on
the scraps of it I mean I got I got
these references uh in some cases
from um nothing like this one here this
this all about paper I didn't know about
him and the referee had told me about it
um and uh gave me no clue as to what
spie was and uh
um and a lot of other stuff
and uh you know working a while I was
able to finally locate this this report
uh and I had it in my hands and most a
lot of people just copying their
bibliography they copy uh from somebody
else's bibliography or something like
that and then and errors tend to
propagate for a long time Ellen
burlecamp said when he did his book on
coding Theory and he checked every
reference in the bibliography uh in the
library and he found almost 50 percent
uh who they would have been wrong if he
had simply had done it by citing
um uh uh the references that he that he
was given because of accumulated errors
in other bibliography so it's so uh it's
you know so it's good you should check
your things uh directly but here they're
they're they're asking authors to be
really you know so somebody who didn't
work as hard as I did will have a lot
more of these questions sitting on there
to do in 48 hours yeah and suggests
submitting the location of conference
generally yeah
um in the in the handbook for Scholars
it says uh uh don't you don't need that
yeah and um and I I bet you why they
asking for it though is that that a lot
of libraries now are beginning to uh
file these
um uh you know you have a conference
file and it'll be by City And so and so
you know people say I don't know I don't
remember the name of this conference but
I remember that it was that it was held
in Toledo you know and and so there
probably weren't that many conferences
held in Toledo so they look it up and
under Toledo and then they can scan for
it so so this is a way of of doing it um
for for uh for retrieval that that
sometimes uh I sometimes I don't know
the difference between location of
conference and city of conference
yeah maybe so okay
yeah with all the things that they say
I'm okay or a question mark is is there
a standard way to say yes it's okay I
usually Circle the okay that's the
that's what I usually do I mean that's
what they usually that's the convention
I I I've seen before yeah um uh they
it's not sometimes you know they give
you a choice Circle listen but uh but it
looks like this is very clean I won't
have to do very much changing on this uh
on these galaxies they they had a lot of
people working over these already it's
it uh they must have a big budget or
something these years okay it's much
better than
it much better than five years ago and
certainly much better than 20 years ago
in the kind in the quality of galleys
that it got here
well Nick on Friday I'll tell you
whether that reading it holds true after
I've looked at them carefully
um
yeah let's see anything else interesting
they show you proofreaders marks here uh
but they don't they don't specifically
say how to
they don't specifically answer your
question Alan
but these are the standard proofread
marks you find over and over again
they're getting much more standard as
they used to always be standard but
different with every publisher but now
they're they tend they tend to be uh
overlapping a lot more than
than other than than before and so but
they remind us of they remind you of
this each time what they what what to do
and so on oh well
so that's that it's nice to to actually
finish something once in a while
and so it's usually something you don't
mind doing this 48 hour job even though
it interrupts you at a random time okay
now today the main thing I want to talk
about today was uh is the still
um
uh user manuals and nobody has given me
examples of terrible a terrible uh
glitches and user manuals so that means
that that either you didn't try you know
take me seriously or or that you don't
notice anything wrong with the user
manuals of the world or I mean as
computer scientists maybe we we think
they're okay or something like that but
I do have something to show you about
user manuals anyway because this is a
class that I get that I taught
um
a year ago or I guess it was only a half
a year ago where the uh the students in
304 last spring quarter were given two
weeks to to work on a project that
involved user interface and design of a
manual and the requirement in the
problem was that the manual had to fit
on one page
and I was going to actually have it was
going to be designed for some of the
people here recognize that they were
that they were involved in this
experiment yes I see don't blush so much
here but but I'm saying that you had
only two weeks to work on it guys right
so
so um and and for this purpose I brought
in on the final day of class I brought
in um quote naive unquote users who
would actually
um be given your user this user manual
for the first time to look at it and to
learn how to use the system now what's
the system what the system was supposed
to be for a specific uh uh thing which
is and I call it digiflash uh and and
this is uh for this is a uh um a sign
that was I think was eight bits uh uh
high and 256 bits wide and it consisted
of uh flashing dots or you know white
dots that could could turn on and off
and uh so uh you see these signs around
in uh in stores and and things now and
the idea was that we were now going to
make
designs much more usable for the
customer by having having a great uh
software first of all uh that would that
would
do need the visual effects but also the
user should be able to learn these how
to do these effects easily and the
manual would explain how to how to do it
because these people who are using the
sign don't do this for a living they
just want to to make a you know they
want to they want to make something that
their customers can see but that's not
their expertise to do the signs so so
um this was the the Ninja flash
experiment and the uh sort of the the
model of the story was that that the
people in digiflash were all Engineers
who know how to design these these signs
but they didn't know anything about
software and they didn't know anything
about writing and so the students of
cs304 were being calling as consultants
to solve all these problems for them and
they were supposed to design great
great software and and then explain to
the user how to do it all right
um now
uh we got four Solutions each was done
by a team of people and I said they had
on two weeks to do it
and uh
um the solutions uh
look extremely good compared to what you
I mean what what uh I mean you know sort
of in the computer science Emilio if we
stayed inside the Margaret Jackson Hall
these solutions would all who would all
look Elementary and uh and and excellent
um but as I said I brought these real
naive users you know my wife for example
who came in to um to look at the system
and then we all of a sudden found out
that uh there are other people in the
world that don't think this quite the
same way as as those of us in Margaret
Jackson Hall and um
and and so uh there I mean there are
people who don't know what a menu is
except in the restaurant and then uh and
and especially they never they didn't
know the word scroll uh what that means
uh a scroll isn't that something that
you sometimes see in Old you know uh in
temples or something
um or in in museums so
um
uh was so uh
every you know one of the things that
you do on on these signs is have letters
uh move across the screen
but everybody in computer science land
would call this scrolling across the
screen but they but they didn't explain
that this this word to the you know they
just use it assuming that everybody knew
what it was and this kind of thing
happens uh um
more more than uh uh than any of us
realize until we until we Face the uh
the real audience for the thing okay
well now I'll show you the four
Solutions uh uh and I and the um
not dwelling too too long on the first
one the first one was the least
successful but I want to sort of give an
increasing order of acceptability here
uh of of sorry not acceptability of um
of um uh what do you call it uh Clarity
um
and uh and and the first the first
approach was to to give a very logical
user manual
um now this is one of the things that uh
we can we can uh um you know that that
uh we might assume then that that since
we're computer scientists and we uh are
very logical thinkers and we put things
down into algorithms step by step but
this is really the way to everybody in
the world prefers to have to have this
thing packaged for them and so um and so
here we have a a very logical
presentation
um
creating a message
by the way there was no introduction
saying why you'd want a message or what
a message is or something like that but
that's okay we can I don't think that
caused people to block but this got down
into you can create six different types
of messages
Capital messages six it's not spelled
out well these messages uh this time the
S is is is is this cap
uh differ from each other in one the way
they scroll read scroll on the screen
that's what that's cute what doesn't
communicate
looking at this once to find out how to
use the the this beast that's just been
handed right okay and so so then there's
um
um uh one sub a either the message
starts from off screen I.E starts with a
blank screen and Scrolls the message
from left from right to left
um characters enter from the right end
and fall off the Left End of the screen
or B the and so on with the message left
indented now notice this I don't know
now I gotta talk about ie here people
are I'm not sure what to say about ie I
might take all the IES out of the book
I'm writing now although it seems to me
that's it's something that uh I mean is
it formal or is it something that
everybody understands as a part of our
language and and reads right by it and
knows exactly it's just the right word
do you have to change that to some other
word like that is namely or can you say
I.E and still and still be communicating
well without uh uh to to people I don't
know the answer to that but I do know
that I would never
use IE with uh without a comma after it
I um I was taught that by somebody or
other that I should better i e g and ie
I should always have to be followed by
some other punctuation but
um that minor thing the punctuation here
is funny because it never has a space
after it
is a comma n period characters you know
and is this is is this uh oh here's a
space there you know now now that's you
know maybe that's a maybe this is the
new style that I just didn't know um uh
it's an old style It's actually an old
style it's the way you think it's the
way people used to do it in the 15th
century but um but um and I think in
France uh the comment tends to be uh
sort of still straddle uh a space
between uh or at least it did in the 30s
uh you can see uh uh James Joyce when it
was when it was banned in America it was
printed in English in in Paris and all
the comments were funny
um but um
uh okay this is a now anyway there
wasn't any attention paid to
presentation here of of um of little
details like that but but the main the
main problem about you as far as user
manual is concerned is that here it's
very logical we have six ways which is
equal to two times three you get to
choose these two or you have to do do
these now instead of explaining the
logical structure like this which might
seem really great to a computer
scientist I think what turns out that
there's other other ways that work that
work more effective and we'll be seeing
them later on in this as we see the
other solutions that people have so in
other words
um uh
the formal definitions are not are not
the way for me to explain something to
my to my uh cousins uh who are younger
than I am so on uh I learned that when I
took you know when I'm when I meet them
at Family reunions and I imagine other
people are like that too uh when you go
out in the real world
here they have something called Left
indented the message left indented now
what does left indented mean it says the
first character of the message is on the
left end of the screen
now that is a rather strange use of the
word uh even if you're defining a
technical term indented to me means
moved in
from the margin but here they're saying
it's flush with the margin it's it's
right at it's right at the market so
it's called Left indented which which is
just sort of left uninvented they they
they they left it without indenting it I
mean
all right well
um okay and then look at what look what
happens here type of message one to six
now this is a great user interface type
a number from one to six right uh I mean
there must be some you have a whole
keyboard there and instead and what and
what they decided was that you know type
in a number from one to six and uh and
remember what those numbers are
um after identifying one of the six
combinations
uh okay you
you uh you will be prompted the screen
will say such and such you should now
enter the text or the message you want
to screen when this enter is very
um uh what do you call it it's all in
caps and it sort of makes the user
intense oh I'm not going to enter it
okay
and um uh this is I mean I don't know
there must be a way to do this we have
to remember that also that these users
are frightened of the dying machine when
they come into the thing and they're
trying to make them feel a little
comfortable
and uh okay now so my wife says the
first thing she wants to see in a user
manual is always how to get back in case
you make a mistake how to make sure that
you can recover and that you aren't
breaking anything and and
um and user manuals tend to to uh leave
this for some something that's even hard
to find in the index I mean and and for
example different different basic uh
interpreters I uh have different ways of
stopping and everybody who writes a
manual for how to use basic on their
system seems to assume that you're never
going to do anything in the world except
except be running basic and you will
never want to get back to the system and
some and sometimes some of you type
exits let me type quit so many type
systems I mean type you know and and but
how do you find this by looking in the
index there's no way to say how to stop
but you know without without shutting
the darn machine off and and so you know
the users often that's the main question
they want to know and and uh it's not
addressed in in a write-up okay so uh
but they did actually have a single
called exiting which uh I I don't think
I use it would know what exiting means
but but if the question is addressed
here on on one page okay another
solution was given
um
uh let's see which um
oh I'm not sure how to order these now
um but it's uh it's uh has a clever
thing here digiflash TM uh to show how a
lot of people are have to be you know
preserve their uh their trademark
TM means that you claim it as a
trademark but it isn't registered
um uh you can anybody can say TM
anything they want then but if it says
an r with a circle in it that means it's
actually gone through and has some legal
status but uh but it's nice to say this
anyway to try to protect you
um
welcome to digiflash TM a tool which
which
tool that will allow you to create your
own signs okay that's nice though I mean
except for the witch in in just a few
minutes you will learn to make signs
which
will give your customers important
information about your products and or
prices and generally attract attention
to your business a digiflash TM sign is
made up of a sequence of messages which
you type in these messages can be long
or short and contain flashing or bold
face letters to emphasize your special
points to emphasize special points of
your text this sequence of messages is
displayed continuously until you turn
the machine off so once you tell
digiflash TM what you want it to say you
don't have to worry about it again until
you wanted to say something else if so
the basic idea of this x position is
good it's uh it's introducing it then we
have the standard thing it's design
threading is very easy to learn and very
easy to correct mistakes you make
so enjoy this is nice to so enjoy
um and and I guess it's nice to to also
to know that that the people who
presented this thought it was easy to
learn
but it makes you feel a little bit
you find out that that you couldn't
learn it
um okay now all right well
um
uh it says to use any of these fonts in
your message hold the option key down
while typing one of the following Keys F
flashing B bold V reverse video
now
um
reverse video I suppose is a common term
there who are you laughing about rent
huh
no
but I got a lap out of the left back
there Scott what what what's the
PMR oh R for reverse video yeah yeah
that's true
I would have been would have been kind
of natural for reverse yeah back black
and white reverse
um but this is the worst this is this I
think is the the the real glitch in this
solution says then type the text you
want to emphasize and then type the same
keystroke option with FB or V to enter
more normal text now as you're using
this this just seems completely wrong
psychologically you're sitting there and
you type and you type B to get bold and
so now you type in things and and and
you have a wysiwyg system so so now if
you type B all of a sudden you're seeing
bold letters as you type in there and
now you want to type normal letters
again so what do you what do you what do
you press B and the B now makes it takes
you back to normal
see what I mean it should be an N right
much much uh I mean even even I think
that way I mean you know I'm not a uh
you know I'm a very logical person but I
think uh you know always you know this
you know if you want to change the style
of letters type option and and n and
then you would change the style of
letters what if you wanted to type
banana in bold no no I don't hold the
app I don't hold the option key down
except except to switch to uh all right
to get to uh you know this is the option
so so so you know it should really say
option b not you know then you take away
take off the option key and he's like
you say banana
um and there was some more characters
with option one would give you an
airplane and stuff like this and hearts
and stuff
um and they had a neat feature here
option minus would give you the current
time
and I didn't have time to play with it
to see if this time was up
updated if you could make a bank type of
a sign um
uh or if it would just give you the time
that was current at the time at the time
you you created the message
um okay and now you can use the word
scroll and but they have something here
because they try this one slowly
materialize and so they had a way of of
getting getting messages in and out
um
and uh editing the messages this was the
key thing that the user had to learn and
was uh
um and it was addressed only at the sort
of as an appendix but say this is easy
to do it while it's displaying your
message you may notice a mistake
um and that's but the thing is the users
made the mistakes right at the beginning
and it was it was a little harder to to
learn it but I guess just to find that
part of the of a manually
um do I have any other comment on this
not to
not much um uh there would actually
there was uh
it would have from a computer science
standpoint I think uh eight eight uh
type Styles instead of four would I mean
they have normal bold flashing in
Reverse but these aren't usually
exclusive you could have
you could have flashing bold and you
know black and white versus
black versus white pole versus normal
and flashing versus uh not flashing uh
we're fairly easy to learn learn now
this overrides the other one yeah
I I don't know
uh otherwise how would you get back I am
you don't say normal so anyway yeah yeah
yeah
anyway yeah um
okay so um now this uh uh
uh I think this solution um
was this the one that no I don't know
anyway
as far as the write-up is concerned um
uh we gotta move on because it's because
the uh the last one is the best and I
want to get to I don't want to minimize
it uh now here's another one which uh uh
well this the title is just isn't isn't
in joke for the class the Dykstra
digiflash uh we had we had five problems
in this course two weeks on each problem
and uh and each of the first four
problems had some connection with with
Holland in the Netherlands and we just
noticed this as a theme and we didn't
see any connection between fifth problem
and Netherlands but it turned out that
this particular group had had the
initials of the people had had a Vijay
and a k and St and so on but that was
that's not part of the uh of the real I
mean that's just the end joke for the
class now your digiflash unit will
repeatedly display a message made up of
a sequence of lines which you enter
that's okay which there by the way no
also under your control is the motion
style of each line as it is brought into
and out of the field of view the concept
fairly good subhead there and it's not
too bad uh entering a line at the sign
of the flashing bar now that's kind of
reasonable too
um
instead of calling it a cursor which
other people
did they Define a cursor I think in one
case it defined a cursor and then never
use the term
to the rest of the page
um but um
um here it's color flashing vertical
barn and uh that's useful oh here it
says cursive I think this might be the
one where it doesn't need to to actually
refer to it because it's not used
anywhere else so you could get by with
just call it the flashing the flashing
bar and that was as you as people are
typing it in it was fairly easy to
understand that
aspect of it
um
and uh there's questions you know the
the somebody who never used the machine
before has to know about the return key
and things like that other people would
just say enter it and they wouldn't and
they would sit there and never know what
it was the last the last thing to do
obviously
um but um
now
um so what did I say here um
on this so um
the left and right arrow keys may be
used to position the cursor I.E the
flashing bar anywhere within the line
move the cursor to the left of some
character this was the only place the
cursor was used and hit the up or down
arrow key a few times to change the
character style so now let's see I
suggested rewriting this in my notes
Here
I said continue calling it because
they're flashing bar
uh don't use a formal Latin term like IE
even if you punctuate it properly here
was another way of punctuating I.E i
period e colon
um
and um and so
I I suggested changing this the
sentences are long here so I suggest a
changing it for something like this turn
on your digiflash you will see a
flashing vertical bar this means it's
ready for you to type when you hit a key
a letter appears where the bar was
flashing try it
to remove a letter you don't want hit
backspace
and get the idea shorter sentences
these sentences read
read
reasonably good English but they're long
sentences and they and uh they're sort
of mouthfuls you know to to when you're
learning you could do it with with the
very direct approach okay and then there
was a
motion style idea here
um so this is a
a formal concept which is being for a
formal explanation it's all right but
maybe the user doesn't want isn't into
formals context so you'll be asked to
specify the motion style of the line
exit and this is a kind of a computery
aspect but you so you can say it you can
say they you can get the concept across
without making it formal I think
available styles are scroll wipe to
flash yeah wipe is more like flush isn't
it like flash and split and you can hit
question mark for a demonstration now
that was that was good in other words
yeah explain you know have a feature
where the where the thing where you you
know you can just have them have the
machine uh show you what is what these
things mean uh and and so they they
could give an animated uh presentation
instead of trying to do it in words
besides saving them uh I mean making it
easier because I gave them a one-page
restriction and so they could put
everything else into the into the
machine itself
um for example so for example you have
the line scroll in and then flash out
and um now some kind of uh and then
choosing link for the exit motion this
was something that none of the users
were able to pick up
uh what this what this meant it was a
concept that uh was a little more
complicated to explain
um but um
the the uh this question mark option
would demonstrate link if you if if you
used it
um
uh
and um
uh so so having having some kind of
online documentation is certainly uh is
certainly valuable with all these stuff
all these things um
uh the trouble with this system really
wasn't so much in the write-up though as
in the uh as in the user interface which
would go through prompting for five
things for every line
uh it would say you know
message motion style and then enter that
and then
the other one and there was and and the
defaults
uh were uh if you had it I don't know it
would it would always be fought to a
certain motion style even though
previously you had said that you wanted
scrolling it would still give you
flashing for or whatever the one default
but that was
it means I want to show you mostly this
this last one which which I felt was the
most successful uh can we have the whole
page just instead of yeah the words
first of all just to see this this is
the page uh manual now which has um
which has visuals uh and it and it
contains uh
uh some some uh you know
some kind of helpful redundancy it's it
doesn't say everything only once it it
had it's it has things that you can find
it
um as the person approaches the manual
they they never read it no you know in
the way you want them to uh you know I
never did I tell you this before that I
whenever I see somebody pick up one of
my books in the bookstore I see that
they open it to the middle and they
start reading there and I never plan
them to to to do that I I planned him to
read the preface you know and then go
into chapter one and so on and I and I
don't know how to stop them doing this
but they do it
now now when you do this manual when you
do this manual you're going to find that
people are aren't you know they're gonna
they're not gonna start at the beginning
and and and read through it but they're
going to say hmm this is an interesting
play I wonder what to do and then I I
see something here and then I'll read
that and then I'll I'll try pushing a
button or something like that
um
well this has useful redundancy I think
so it starts out but it has an overview
sort of compulsory to have an overview
some people like to read an overview
other people will never read this
section
um or maybe on in an emergency
um but um but the step-by-step looks
pretty good step one type step two play
step three fancy display step four play
again step five experiment and it and it
and this is but this is nice this mainly
in the style of the writing the short
sentences so now we can get closer on
here uh can we zoom up now
so type in your first message use the
recur TurnKey to begin a second one the
first message disappears but don't fear
the computer still remembers it and
things like this okay
um play hold this um this is uh we're
using a Macintosh for the demo so we got
this key that that has this neat symbol
on it and people can understand that
symbol better than calling it The
control key or all right which are the
options and press P look
Ninja flash is playing your messages one
after the other
to go back to editing use that e okay
now I would probably say uh oh and now
it says and here it says movement and
then it's it and then it has this while
holding this press and and so these are
you know this is a summary of the of
things that you can do
and um I think it might have been a
little better to say well
that you that you that somehow they're
holding it down uh you're not just sort
of holding it I mean that's uh
uh you'd be surprised how many people
who
understands but um
anyway uh this is uh uh a lot of times
but it's it's because it's it's good to
emphasize that you don't first press
this and then the other one I mean a lot
of people most people will make that
that mistake and they won't be used to
having a typewriter where your whole you
know the shift key maybe but but uh you
know you wouldn't never to some of these
other things
um now um
uh so but the writing here was was a
good way to to uh in general I think the
the uh the pace of the sentences say you
want a message to Blink find the message
uh you know three letters three word
sentences eight were senses and more
journalistic style here
play the sequence again now your message
blinks
um
now um the
uh the the least successful part of this
award went was the description of up and
down uh because uh you have there's not
an obvious concept of what up and down
means I I um when you have only one line
of a message
um and uh so probably choosing another
word
um saying a previous message following
message or something like that instead
of up and down would have uh in the in
the uh in this write-up would say
previously after you know something like
that uh would would be good but the the
uh the least successful part of this of
this chart was was this um uh was this
line here can anybody figure out what
this line means well it's highlighted by
the way uh in um in my uh with a yellow
uh highlighter magic marker
uh which you could see there are yeah
beautiful in color over there on this on
the other screen
um and
and uh uh there's uh there was a nice
idea here when you're when you're using
the machine it had an icon that they
would put in at the beginning telling
you what the different
um what the different things you had you
didn't have to call it a menu but you
could have just said options
um uh but um it says hold blink scroll
up scroll down scroll left scroll right
you could use in other words instead of
scroll probably move
but these were the the ways in which
that line could could be described oh
yeah sometimes it cause this calls it a
message sometimes it calls it a line
and probably be better to um
to to stick to one of those two
words
um
and then it says use space to go through
options and so it turns out that you if
you push the space bar it'll change the
option
you know the and and the icons were
reasonable that that is a icon you know
have having
um some kind of a picture here you you
you're dealing with a a very small
screen only eight bits high and only 256
bits wide but we still want to
communicate with the user and this
little picture was was was uh quite
reasonable a hold of uh blink uh move
you know the message moves into
something but
um I don't
I'm just I didn't understand this line
does anybody understand what it means
Julia
yeah
message
the potential office
yeah yeah you got yeah okay you got it
so I
and and so I I would um
uh so my my first thought on it would
have would have said something like it's
an extra long message can be seen if you
make it move
that would have been what I what I put
in this in this line here so I'll say an
extra long message can be seen if you
make it move and then and then uh talk
about movement under options this this
this instead of saying scroll left it
would say move the message to the left
something like that okay
um
okay and um uh there's one other thing
that I I that I wanted to comment on
especially here it's this is uh this
last sentence here says don't worry
digiflash 2 has been carefully
redesigned not to bite
now
now this was a little this was
apologetic
um yeah in other words it says you know
you might have talked to some of our
other customers
you know
um but we have the new Improvement on
now so don't listen to them you know
um
you don't but you know if it hadn't been
redesigned that would have been a fairly
good sense you know it would say that
there's not you know you have to hang
something in here saying you can't hurt
this machine and it can't hurt you then
that would be very useful to a lot of
users but the thing that has been
carefully redesigned not to buy that
loses maybe they were assuming that the
people had seen the other team's
attempts
oh maybe so but it doesn't come through
that way to me
um so um
okay and then um uh another nice thing
at the end here it says step five
experiment you are already on Master
digiflash 2 program d slash two oh I see
a programmer make flashy signs to your
heart's content if you need to insert a
line use this could delete a line use
that good luck
um Good Luck that's you know very very
user friendly right there
okay any more comments
now so so Wednesday herb wolf and then
on Friday I will I think I'm going to
talk on Friday about uh uh either
refereeing or about
um about making illustrations for for
paper